[Musik]
ich finde die idee eines dienst jahres
sehr sehr gut ich glaube dass man
verantwortung lernen muss auch gerade in
der freien gesellschaft
und ich glaube dass ganz gutes wenn
junge leute das lernen und zwar in der
ganzen breite der gesellschaft junger
menschen aus einem sozialen brennpunkt
die sonst vielleicht wenig wertschätzung
erfahren wenig anerkennung erfahren
können eben lernen dass sie gebraucht
werden und auch junge menschen aus der
behüteten elternhaus oder die man zu den
eliten dieser gesellschaft zählen kann
sollten über so einen dienst lernen wie
es in anderen teilen der gesellschaft
aussieht und dass sie ihre besondere
stellung in der gesellschaft eben der
gesamtgesellschaft verdanken dass ich
nicht los gekoppelt davon existieren
können
[Musik]
ich glaube mit einer wehrpflichtarmee
ist uns unter dem gesichtspunkt
einsatzbereitschaft und
auftragserfüllung derzeit nicht geholfen
interessant wäre die frage wenn man das
wehrpflicht prinzip umdreht und sagt
jeder macht ein soziales pflichtjahr ob
ein teil dieser jungen menschen dieses
jahr auch in den streitkräften ableisten
könnte das wäre ein aspekt der für uns
spannend wäre
wir haben einen freiwilligen wehrdienst
derzeit dem könnte man auch
weiterentwickeln und ausbauen um sich
dem sozusagen zu nähern aber der fokus
liegt in der allgemeinen
gesellschaftlichen debatte so wie ich es
erleben
auf dieser sozialen komponente nicht um
arbeitskräfte zu ersetzen sondern um zu
unterstützen der klassische zivi hat
auch keine pflegekraft ersetzt sondern
der war derjenige der zeitfenster noch
mal geschaffen hat indem er gesagt hat
ich übernehme hol und bringdienst ich
räume das schon mal auf dann können sie
sich noch mal länger unterhalten der es
auch nochmal stehen geblieben und hatte
ein offenes ohr und diese tätigkeiten
die unterstützen sind dafür glaube ich
gibt es einen enormen bedarf und dann
wahrscheinlich wird das so ähnlich sein
wie es früher beim wehr und zivildienst
auch der fall war wird es viele junge
menschen geben die sagen ich hätte mir
nie vorstellen können sozialen beruf zu
lernen aber das genau mein ding
[Musik]
ich gehe davon aus dass die partei das
in ihr neues grundsatzprogramm schreiben
wird sicherlich kann man damit wunderbar
mit liberalen grünen und anderen dann
streiten öffentlich aber das finde ich
gerade gut wenn die cdu in ihrem
programm alleine alleinstellungsmerkmal
hat wo sie sich von anderen sehr
deutlich unterscheidet und da muss man
in wahlen politische mehrheiten dafür
finden und so lange man die nicht hat
bin ich sehr der meinung müsste die
bestehenden freiwilligendienste deutlich
deutlich ausbauen es gibt eine größere
bereitschaft sich freiwillig auch ein
jahr lang für die gesellschaft zu
engagieren als wir denken